berlin 10 uhr 45 vergangenen samstag
mehrere demonstrationen gegen die korona
politik der bundesregierung soll es
heute geben das motto der größten
kundgebung ein fest für freiheit und
frieden durchs brandenburger tor darf
keiner ziehen die route ist für die
straße des 17 juni angemeldet die
polizei tut was ihre aufgabe ist und
schon ist es mit dem frieden vorbei
[Musik]
auftritt eines mannes der den anschein
eines reporters weg sekunden später ist
es mit dem objektiven blick vorbei
der vermeintliche reporter heißt
matthäus wie ein rechter youtuber der
regelmäßig auf corona demos stimmung
macht antisemitische klischees vom
jüdischen banker nicht daran so und wird
über 150 nationalbank auf der welt bei
190 staaten von den kontrolliert sind
dann wissen wir welche last einer hand
hat aber carola ist unsere zeit
matthäus weh meint es ernst wie sich
wenige stunden später auf den treppen
des reichstages zeigen wird
gegen 11 uhr der pariser platz ist gut
gefüllt es weht schwarz weiß rot die
fahnen des untergegangenen deutschen
reichs eine zeit in der ein kaiser das
letzte wort und seine untertanen wenig
zu melden hatten
heute darf jeder seine meinung sagen
ganz öffentlich und in jede kamera
der mann der ard und zdf so hasst nennt
sich regner nach eigenen angaben
verurteilt wegen raubüberfall und mord
er ist in die rechtsextreme szene gut
vernetzt und er will kämpfen
alles was da oben ist in berlin muss
fixiert werden alles was ihm bei 1 ist
weg geschickt werden auch wegner meint
es ernst was sich am abend noch zeigen
wird
11.23 die polizei deeskaliert gibt dem
weg durchs tor frei wer heute
demonstriert weiß das grundgesetzt an
seiner seite
schließlich hatte ein gericht das vom
berliner innensenator verhängte
versammlungsverbot aufgehoben
und das volk hat sich auch dieser mann
mit blau gestreiften jackett gemischt
nicolai nerling ein selbsternannter
volks lehrer entlassen aus dem
schuldienst wegen volksverhetzung stand
er vor gericht ein auftritt bei
rechtsradikalen würde wirklich hier
wohlfühlen würde auch nerling wird es
heute noch zum reichstag ziehen
dort herrscht gegen 12 uhr noch
ziemliche ruhe
es ist die ruhe vor einem angekündigten
sturm seit tagen wurde in chats mobil
gemacht
das haus der deutschen besitzen
der reichstag das ist der richtige
ansatz reichstag mit millionen besetzen
und rücktritt der regierung fordern
kanzleramt reichstag und diese [ __ ]
dorthin aufhängen wenn es nach mir gehen
würde
12 uhr 30 die sogenannte versammlung für
die freiheit kommt auf der
friedrichstraße zum stehen alles
friedlich gegen 13 uhr eine ansage
[Musik]
die organisatoren rufen dazu auf sich
den anweisungen zu widersetzen weil
corona für sie nicht existiert kommen
masken nicht in frage das holen wir
nicht und deswegen bleibe ich mir
deswegen werden wahrscheinlich auch die
meisten anderen hier bleiben den aufbau
einer eskalation führen
dann führt die polizei einzelne ein mann
in bundeswehruniform ergreift das wort
diese lang verteidigen wenn sie mal zur
verteidigung zur reserve die uniform
durch erwarten stellt mit waffe dagegen
die friedrichstraße zur mittagszeit ein
hauch von staatsstreich liegt in der
luft die demo veranstalter wollen das
nicht gern im fernsehen sehen
die free nicht er sei die rechte
ihr seid es nazi wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr
15 30 zigtausende sind zur
hauptkundgebung gekommen hauptredner
michael walbeck spricht auf einer weit
entfernten bühne
es geht ihm längst um viel mehr als
corona das grundgesetz soll ersetzt
werden über dem platz schallt die
aufforderung zur selbstermächtigung das
fordern auch raichs bürger und keine
zwei kilometer weiter unter den linden
können einige es kaum abwarten und
schlagen los
[Applaus]
gegen 17 uhr greift die polizei durch
eben reichs bürger und verschwörungs
anhänger nehmen wollen die das nicht
gegen 19 uhr scheint alles vorbei zu
sein
doch plötzlich sirene geschichte
geschrieben
die korrupte verbrechen festgenommen
rick wegner der mann der die regierenden
in berlin wegfegen wollte hat die erste
sperren zum reichstag überwinden
nicolai nerling der selbsternannte volks
lehrer setzt sich in szene will dabei
sein ganz form auch matthias w der
rechte youtuber mittendrin
nur kurz gibt er den pressemann dann
fällt auch diese masken aufruf zur
blockade nach knapp zehn minuten endet
der spuk die polizei räumt rechtsextreme
reichs bürger und ihre mitläufer von den
stufen des parlaments
die bilanz des tages 33 verletzte beamte
131 strafanzeigen und 316 festnahmen
abzug der verlierer
das kaiserreich es bleibt geschichte
[Musik]